The Joe Rogan Experience on that show I
tell a joke about Bigfoot I never saw
Bigfoot but I was when we were trying we
were on train and you do these training
where you go make maps and all this [__]
and we heard him you heard breakfast all
right what's it sound like hey
I could still do that he does that but
he everything you see on them stupid TV
shows
that happened he threw a rock
all the animals started running and the
Marine because you know he's the guy who
knows where the markers are but we
didn't know where the markers were he's
the one who says hey
we're out of perimeter have you guys
ever heard of Big Clip he was Native
American
but he just said that and where were you
guys what state uh like Nova Scotia Nova
Scotia where they do cold weather
training yeah and you have to make your
own magic you sure they weren't [__]
with you
I'm pretty sure who to do through that
rock somebody that was [__] with you
no I don't know why you [__] with the
animals dude all the animals ran into
remember how you said they know how to
get away damn all these [__] just
they just did a little Mass accidents
and it's a it's an all very skeptical
Bigfoot
I've never seen him but I never heard
nothing like that either but so what if
you had a did it sound like uh it just
sounded it it was uh what was it similar
to
yeah Luther Vandross second line
oh my God
like when you hear him on a record it's
one thing but when you hear him live
he's like
like that he didn't sound like that but
it was the same power power like hair on
the back of your neck kind of what the
[__] well you know bears do that
sometimes
Bears uh especially when what you what
time of the year was it it was it was
Winter because
you listen to the wind it's like it
sounds like a train coming you have to
determine where the wind is coming from
and like get like on a tree or something
because a lot of the um icicles are
coming like darts oh wow Jesus and that
night we were joking I was joking around
about it and everything and one of the
officer says you know this is a facility
and you know we don't heard your
comedian we don't make you basically you
can't you can't go on stage and go hey
guess where I was at yeah yeah so I just
I was just in the joke I'm just camping
and we uh oh I see yeah but there's
nobody's in the military but we and in
the joke I actually do see Bigfoot it's
so funny so tell me so how did it happen
what was going on what were the
circumstances
we were laid out for me okay yeah you
have uh
you get because it's cold and it's
raining and so we're like in a little
circle
it was and it's kind of raining kind of
sleet and we're talking about you know
we're gonna do this and do that because
we're comparing [__] and everybody's
[__] up we found our third marker
first like and it's supposed to be like
a two or three day thing right and
they're good teams like you do it in the
classroom for a couple days and then a
team goes out team come back team goes
that and some of the guys who weren't as
good as us in the classroom we're coming
right back in two days
they just spent the night spent one
night and came back [__] man we was on
our third day though
and then our first marker was the third
marker but he couldn't help us but then
after we heard that he's like look
you guys [__] up because we're
so how long did it take in total oh we
left right after that dog he told us
he didn't want to be there the morning
we wanted to be there
so yeah it's a lot of fudging going on
oh okay so he said yeah good enough it's
good enough so you guys were out there
and uh explained to me what happened and
who was telling you that it's Bigfoot
well we all heard it we're like
everybody's like what the [__] and then
everything's running deer and
everything's just like discouraging but
we heard you know you throw a stick
through the branches
like it's just like a big something just
flew through the trees and then asked
for he's he he's kind of you know and of
course we like [__] out of here right
but it was it was just it was just too
weird to yeah and then he was like yeah
you guys missed your other markers I
might know where they are so we just
kind of
we're out dude we're out like 20 miles
you have to be right there with Bigfoot
whoa I wasn't really worried about
Bigfoot because from According to that
dude Bigfoot don't bother you
Husband by the other animals so that
dude seen Bigfoot before I don't know if
he's seen him before but he just said
you know but he just lets you know when
you've gone too far in the woods really
like nobody wants to believe nobody ever
says it he grabs you and do not he just
does warning things just like on those
stupid TVs you ever watch those shows oh
yeah oh yeah we heard the sad quads yeah
and you that's been the least successful
successful show ever yes they've been
trying to find Bigfoot for like eight
seasons I've spent the whole day on the
road like if I'm running my hotel I
spent the whole day oh [__] they about
to get it oh [__]
yeah me too and then I'm like it's five
o'clock they got me again
go get something to eat you know yeah
that's not those aren't so successful
yeah I mean the best they get is like a
sound
reality shows man they're not really
reality they they [__] around they [__]
around with editing you know I was on
one of those what do you do the naked
one a naked one yeah
I had a uniform on and we all got bugs
yeah so I know yeah oh my God the
suffering yeah also I don't know if they
look at how how bad can you get [__]
up and how quickly can they get you to a
hospital yeah